at the wheel Democrat New York city
councilman Robert Holden joins me now
councilman I've said for a long time
that Democrats who care about regular
working-class people and Republicans who
care about regular working-class people
could work together on this border issue
so what's your message to the White
House tonight
well come up with a plan we haven't
heard a plan it's absurd just let in a
hundred thousand migrants foreign
Nationals I'm vetted foreign Nationals
to New York City and say here take them
we'll we'll uh we'll have to spend eight
million dollars a day in New York City
and again we haven't heard a plan from
this Administration Joe Biden is asleep
at the wheel the whole Administration is
well um the word from secretary mayorkas
and he just testified on Capitol Hill as
you know he said they're managing the
border with the resources that they have
and that the Border sir is not open and
that those who are saying the border is
open
are not telling the truth what is your
response to him
he's lying
we have a hundred thousand uh people in
New York City that walked across uh
unvetted how is that a border how is
that secure
nobody can figure it out this is this is
absurd I mean
we have our eyes here looking at this
outside uh you know the hotel Roosevelt
look at that does that make any sense
whatsoever that this border is secure
well councilman the Texas governor of
course Greg Abbott um they're dealing
with a horrible situation in Texas as
well he tried to set up those buoys in
the Rio Grande to prevent people from
entering the country illegally but the
White House well that's This Is How They
responded
see the the governor doing is dangerous
in an unlawful it's actually hurting the
process it's hurting the process of what
we're trying to do the Department of
Justice has been very clear we've been
very clear about that they've been very
clear about taking him to court about
his unlawful actions
well so a state is trying to do
something their border state to stop the
influx do you believe the White House is
sincere when they say they want to help
your city given the fact that they're
suing Texas
Laura this has been going on for a long
time it's not only this year it's last
year I've I went up to ice I saw
migrants in the hall sleeping in the
hallways they can't handle them by the
way ice is telling us it's take it'll
take 10 years to process the Asylum
applications 10 years
please New York New York can't wait 10
years Chicago can't wait 10 years La
can't wait 10 years uh Robert we really
appreciate you coming on I hope you'll
come back hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else